Speaker 1: Let's go to Vitaly from Iowa. Vitaly
from Iowa, welcome to the David Pacman Show.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. So I have you might
have gotten this question before, but. I
am sort of along the lines where you are. I would
consider myself more of a social Democrat, and I.
I have encountered a lot of my peers who are
more along the lines of democratic socialists,
anarcho communists, etc.. And there's a lot
of infighting. I even get called right wing
sometimes. Okay. So I was wondering what you
would say to that and how to stop all this
infighting that's going on. Well, these are.
Speaker 1: Two very different questions. If I,
as a social Democrat were called right wing,
I would do what I already do, which is to say,
tell me which positions of mine are right wing.
And that usually grinds the conversation to a halt
because it's very hard to name positions of mine
that are right wing. So at the individual level,
Vitali I, when people call you right wing because
you're a social Democrat and not a socialist,
ask them to enumerate your right wing
positions, You know what I'm saying?
Speaker 2: Sure. Okay.
Speaker 1: Now, in terms of more generally about
reducing the in-fighting, I have absolutely no
idea. The reality is that. The infighting on the
right. I believe is more prevalent right now than
been on the left, even though it's very popular to
say the left has all this infighting. It's true.
You can find people on the left who, if you don't
subscribe to every idea about all of these issues,
whether usually with cultural issues, there is a
slice of the left which will say you're not really
on the left, but it's actually relatively small,
whereas on the right the MAGA versus anti
MAGA stuff is really ugly and we'll see to
what extent it's destructive, but it's lost them.
A bunch of elections so far. So, I mean, listen,
it'd be great if the entire left can get on the
same page and then we all sing Kumbaya and all of
this stuff. The reality is that there's a spectrum
of the left from center left Democrats all the way
out to, you know, Leninist left and revolutionary,
left and socialist and all these different things.
If we're really honest, most of the left is on the
same page when it comes to a particular election,
who are we better off with? And that doesn't
mean some people don't stay home or protest
vote or whatever the case may be, but I
actually think the left is quite united.
Speaker 2: All right. Yeah. Thank you for your
insight, David. I just want to say I've been
a subscriber for a few years now, and you were
actually. You helped pulled me out of the MAGA,
right? So I just want to say thank you, sir.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you for your service.
I appreciate it. Yes. All right. There it goes.
Vitale from Iowa with a very powerful declaration